derrick schoevent trial is the biggest
courtroom case of the stream and tvh cnn
from a media perspective the trial form
of minneapolis
police officer derek shoving will be the
biggest trial of streaming tvh people
will be watching on stream and tv
services like long crime
as well as tv networks like hln yeah
it's on twenty force if it's not
24 7. cnn.com will carry a live stream
at all times abc will have a
wall-to-wall coverage on it
abc live news streaming platform cbs
will make it available to feed that's uh
minneapolis
station and the list goes on everybody's
reminiscent of oj almost exactly last
time this is an opportunity obviously
media is going to get a lot of eyeballs
and people you know traffic's coming to
them so
in a way their their business model they
have the next story to go to
but what do you think is going to happen
with them guilty will he be um i i don't
know
i would say that the the problem is that
the average person saw
what the media showed the average
minutes on 46. we saw it
clearly looked like excessive force it
looked horrible
it looked like he killed this guy the
question the people that
the average person doesn't necessarily
understand the law in minnesota
and in order to convict him of what
they're charging him with the question
is what do they need to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt
the question is if they have to prove
that he had the intent
to kill george floyd i think that he has
a good chance of getting off because i
don't know that they can prove
his intent and i don't think he's i
don't think he planned i don't think he
when he was called to the scene he says
oh i have a chance the other thing they
haven't proven is any racism just
because he's white and the other guy's
black doesn't mean it's a racist
event look it looked racist i mean most
people were
completely appalled by it as i was when
i saw it everybody how could you not be
i think there was universal agreement
which is what i don't understand is why
there were all these protests nobody was
defending
chauvin initially but now that they're
learning more
the autopsy showed that the choking
wasn't necessarily the cause of death
and all you need is one juror i mean i'm
a lawyer i understand this you
you you just need one juror to say i'm
not 100 sure and if you're not sure you
can't convict just the way our system
works
so i don't know what they have to prove
i don't know i don't think they went for
first degree murder which probably would
have required
hey he had the absolutely planned it and
he intended to kill this guy
do you think that derek shoved intended
to kill george floyd i don't know i mean
that's no when he woke up that morning i
don't think he was like let me go kill a
guy
let's just let's just go out and kill
somebody especially if he's the wrong
color i don't think that's the way
i mean listen it was it was the depraved
what did the autopsy say
i think the autopsy said he had lethal
amounts of a combination of two
drugs including fentanyl in a system and
i i believe there was also some evidence
that came out that he had some fentanyl
in his pocket or his hand when they were
going to arrest him and he put it in his
mouth and ate that on top of what he was
already high
from all of the the accounts that the
witnesses said he was in the store and
he you know
and apparently passed a a counterfeit
bill whatever it all happened and it
happened very fast
i cannot imagine that he intended to
kill him even as he was doing it because
he knew that
15 people on the sidewalks videoing the
guy he knows if he kills the guy he's
going to ruin his life like why would he
do this
he got wrapped up in the moment i don't
think he had the intent to kill
if anything you know maybe a negligent
homicide uh
maybe manslaughter maybe manslaughter i
don't know what they're charging him
with i haven't looked at the details
i think if they're not careful about if
they get too aggressive and try to
charge them with too much
i think they're going to lose i think he
gets off if they charge him with too
much if they go
to the lower charge yeah they might be
able to get him but i think
you know politically this is this is
going to be very dangerous for our
country
and that's where i'm going with this is
for our country uh again i don't know
where this trial is headed i'm just
thinking of optics we also what happened
when
oj got off or or when uh the rodney king
for the sake of our country and for the
sake of our cities and for the state
again optics here i don't give two shits
about derek shoving he better be charged
with something
like this guy i don't whether he had
drugs in his system or not i don't think
george floyd would have died that day
unless derrick truman's well the knee
was not on his neck that's actually
going to be
a matter of fact they're going to try
we're going to find out but
he either did it i'm thinking of america
i don't i charge this mother sucker with
something
if you let this guy off something bad is
going to be charged do you think he's
going to go i hope so
convicted
i think more likely than not he will but
not necessarily because the facts
show he should be convicted of what he's
charged with i think the jurors are
going to weigh exactly what you're
thinking says if we let this guy off
we're basically we're going to have
blood on our hands we're going to do
some cities burning
people are going to get shot up and you
might say you that's not and that's not
really not appropriate that is not right
that's not how our system works but
again i'm not defending this guy this
guy is not a good guy you think he's
going to get off
i think he is you do i think he is and
it concerns me
i think he is going to get off why does
it cost
why does it concern me are you kidding
me like
america's already the way the media is
selling how divided we are you know
what's going to happen if it gets off
it's a spark but i think it's going to
get off it's going to be ugly i think
it's going to get off because the
autopsy listen
i just think about as a lawyer here
listen this is what the autopsy says
what do you want me to say
yes you know 25 million dollars paid to
the family you know all that stuff
that's already been done
etc etc yes we're going to get rid of
him yes he'll be a limo driver for the
rest of his life type of a thing the
same story with the guy that did what he
did to oj
guess what he is today he's a limo
driver in l.a well the guy that did what
the the cop would not o.j i'm sorry with
the
rodney king the same thing with the cop
that did what he did to rodney king you
can pull up his face
he was on tmz he's a limo driver in lax
okay it's
embarrassing where the guy's talking
saying hey how's it feel knowing what
you did you piece of
you you're now a limo driver how do you
feel about it how do you feel when he's
taking somebody's
so yes the guy's gonna have a miserable
life for the rest of this he didn't kill
rodney king he beat him up i can't
believe they haven't taken that chris
ross what was his name i forget his name
what was the officer's name
the name is a pretty uh uh uh uh if you
go
go to it no no name go back
and put stacy kuhn limo driver i think
that could be it
put stacey [ __ ] limo driver limo
driver i'm amazing i'm amazed they
haven't canceled they canceled that
video that chris rock did how not to get
it
there you go remember that video the
chris rock one how not to get your ass
kicked by the police
have you seen that no i have not when
we're done you should watch it i will i
will definitely watch it so yeah i think
it's gonna be
i think he will be released and i think
oh my gosh it's not how does he live
because what he did eight minutes and 46
seconds and you're watching it's like
dude they're just
you know and then you're watching the
other people that are recording like
even what happened with that lady that
got hit up by this guy
who went in uh uh what do you call it um
uh uh knocked a girl like the asian lady
did you see that with the camera they
kicked her in the face all this stuff
and then later on they found that the
guy stabbed his own wife or his own
girlfriend and killed him and he went to
prison for that and guys are standing on
the side not wanting to do anything
because they're worried if they get
caught what's going to be said all this
stuff
yeah i i i think this is catastrophic
uh i hope you know obviously
we have laws that we have to follow and
it's been set up in a way that you have
to be innocent until proven guilty et
cetera et cetera
and guilt must be proven beyond a
reasonable doubt yeah there's if there's
if there's a reasonable doubt i don't
know i have it here adam yeah i don't
think they have it here and i think
there's a part of what they're charging
him with
that's a very good point if that goes
that route
brace for impact it will be a very
interesting midterm election
i think this is going to be all they
talk about
12 months from now and if it takes that
long how long do you think it's going to
take
uh it could take i don't know it's going
pretty quickly so far
okay all right we'll see so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye